pour 349 contre 186 l'Assemblée
nationale a
[Musique]
adopté les Français ne nous demandent
pas des symboles ils nous demandent de
l'efficacité quand je regarde à
l'extrême gauche je vois ceux qui ont
été élus en faisant l'électoralisme sur
les étrangers
quand je regarde à l'extrême droite je
vois ceux qui ont été élus sur du
populisme contre les
[Musique]
immigrés Madame Le Pen nous ne voulons
pas votre vote cynique et opportuniste
et nous n voudrons jamais si ce texte
est loin d'être parfait nous avons
imposé nous avons imposé des avancées
majeuresation d'une priorité nationale
pour les prestations
sociales rétablissement du délit de
séjours irrégulier déchéan déchéan de
nationalité pour les binationaux qui
s'enprennent notamment à nos forces de
l'ordre cette victoire idéologique cette
reconnaissance de nos solutions prouve
s'il le fallait que la politique que
vous avez mené jusqu'à présent celle du
en même temps ne fonctionne pas ce texte
marque un véritable tournant pour la
première fois depuis longtemps la France
se donne les moyens de reprendre le
contrôle de sa politique migratoire il
est animé par un principe simple moins
d'immigration et plus d'expulsion des
étrangers indésirable le texte c'est
l'annonce d'une catastrophe sociale et
sanitaire la promotion du racisme et du
rejet de l'autre l'introduction de la
préférence nationale l'inscription dans
la loi du programme de Jean-Marie Le
Pen ce projet de loi est un échec dans
une démocratie votre votre projet rejeté
aurait été retiré et le ministre de
l'Intérieur aurait démissionné vous avez
offert à l'extrême droite je cite ces
mots une victoire idéologique majeure
vous avez cédé surt et vous avez surtout
cédé